through the power of mantra Reformation
you know in Sanskrit language they call
it mantra you can actually shape and
create patterns within your mind when he
started to share with me to teach me
that my entire reality was based on what
I believed was real of what I believed
was true about myself about what's
possible and that I could change that
that's when my life started to change
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hate seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn how to
reprogram your mind for success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one shape your mind with dhandapani
subconscious is very moldable you know
sits sits back here in your head and
through the power of mantra or
affirmation you know in sanskrit
language they call it mantra you can
actually shape and create patterns
within your mind and i'm sure when
you're running again i'm assuming that
you say like i can't do this right you
don't say like i know i'm gonna fail
sure right
and through that repetition you create
patterns in your mind so if you follow a
precise technique and system you'd
create patterns and your subconscious
which then become extremely magnetic and
start to attract like-minded people to
its you so I used those techniques I had
affirmations or mantras that I would say
every morning and every night with and
what they consists of is concise charts
of positive words so you never say
something like oh I would like to be
surrounded by successful people but if I
don't it's okay that's not a mantra to
like you know I will surround myself
with financially successful
entrepreneurs who teach me how to be
successful and then it comes to the
second thing that's important is a clear
visualization you have to have a clear
visual concept of what the end product
is
look like and then the third part of it
that's the most important component is
the feeling you have to feel it because
feeling is emotion in motion is energy
and energy is magnetic how do you feel
you remember a feeling of what it's like
to experience sitting with someone who's
a successful entrepreneur spending time
with them walking away and asking
yourself how that felt really great I
learned so much and could really use
these techniques and helping my business
like for example if you win a race you
can remember the feeling of what it's
like right so if you're doing an
affirmation for your next race you say I
will win this race so I can win this
race and you and you visualize that
feeling you had when you won the last
race exactly you visualize yourself
going through the lower ribbon okay your
race is all right you walking through
the ribbon you barbed wire in our case
Bob why exactly lays a fence going
through that and and then the feeling
what the feeling like was the feeling is
like to win that so you hold all three
in your mind at the same time and you
repeat it it creates a pattern in
subconscious which then becomes
extremely magnetic it vibrates at a
particular frequency of that success and
it attracts things of a similar nature
and this works for even negative things
so if I said here I did an affirmation
that said I will be a failure and I
visualized it and I felt it I'll attract
that into my life one of my very first
workshops I did in New York City I
talked about this and the stress all my
monk road but paint and everything and
stuff and at the end of this workshop
this guy comes up to me in a suit and he
says I really enjoyed the workshop but
this whole thing about ma shion's I
don't really believe it I think it's a
bunch of hogwash I said like totally
fine I said look I just left them on the
street like two months ago you know can
you help me prove that what I'm teaching
is wrong
and then and if it's wrong then I'll
promise you I'll never teach it again
sure happy Jay I said what do you do
since I work in Wall Street it's like
okay perfect it was a Sunday I said from
Monday to Friday I want you to say
inefficient 20 times a day all my stocks
all my shares and all my bones are doing
really badly and I'm losing tens of
thousands of dollars I want you to say
those exact words I want you to
visualize all the numbers going down and
I want you to feel what it's like to
lose tens of thousands of dollars in
your investments and once you really
feel it that's the most important thing
I would you do it 20 times a day in
Monday to Friday
didn't mean said no and I offered in $50
you know I didn't have that much money
other than I said often if you say no we
wouldn't do it say if you don't believe
that a negative affirmation would work
why wouldn't you believe right sure you
know right also if you want to have more
motivation self love and confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join are in the description
below you can outwork anybody how bad as
they are the quality of your life is
essentially determined by how you
carried this one yes or no the reason
people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much rule number
two the last one before a very special
bonus clip is follow the blueprints with
John Assaraf I was really fortunate when
I was 19 years old I met a wonderful
gentleman who was very successful with
his family was very successful giving to
charities he was very healthy he was
very gentle and kind and when he started
to share with me to teach me that my
entire reality was based on what I
believed was real and what I believed
was true about myself about what's
possible and that I could change that
that's when my life started to change
and he said if you start to change the
way you think and you start to learn
everyday for one hour to upgrade your
knowledge and your skills and then you
take action every day on the things that
are the most important instead of all
the different things that you can do he
says if you focus on doing three to five
things every day towards your goals he
says in one year you'll be in a totally
different destination three years big
distant five ten years your life won't
be the same and I was tired of living a
mediocre to less than mediocre life and
so I said listen you seem to have a good
plan but you're making millions of
dollars you're giving a lot of money to
charity you're happy you're healthy
you've got a great family
I want that they said if you want that
follow the blueprint don't try to figure
it out just
follow the blueprint and that was
another lesson that he shared with me is
that you don't have to reinvent the
wheel yes
like if you want to fly right now you
don't have to figure out how to fly you
know there's already a blueprint for how
to generate or create an airplane yeah
so if you want to be healthy there's
already a blueprint if you want to make
more money there's already a blueprint
if you want to buy real estate or the
stock market or start a business and
grow business
there's people before us that have
already got the blueprint and all you
have to do is paint paint the numbers
inside the box and then you can use your
creativity
so I just became very good follower for
a long time of things that worked and
when you follow things that work it's
like having the combination to a safe if
somebody gives you the combination to a
safe and they tell you turn this way a
little bit from this way a little bit
turn this way a little bit turn this way
a little bit then open it you can have
access to it but most people don't look
for the combination and then even when
they get the combination they tried in
the wrong order the first thing that you
have to ask is what are your highest
values so for me for example my number
one highest value is God my number two
values my health my number three values
my family my number four value is
contribution to the lives of others my
number v value is fun so every day when
I wake up I think about what am i doing
today to connect with God for me just
for me it doesn't have to be and you
know it's not religious it's just for me
then what do I need to do every day to
make sure that I'm healthy what I need
to do every day to make sure that my
family and my dear close friends are a
part of my family that I have the
relationship that's rich then
contribution how do I use my my passion
my gifts my my stories my things I've
not done well things I have done how do
I share that with the world and in doing
that I feel good and then I have to have
fun and so if I do those five things
every day then at the end of every day
I've had a great day and if you have a
lot of great days then you end up with a
really
life and that doesn't mean that you
don't have ups and downs and things that
don't work and trouble that happens and
things that come up but if you keep your
focus on what's important then the rest
of the stuff is really inconsequential
and there isn't a hundred different
things you have to do there's two or
three things in each one of the areas
that's important to you that when you do
those every day you're so far ahead of
the curve now I have a special bonus
gift from David Goggins on how to
reprogram your mind that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one where do you need to reprogram your
mind number two what is a blueprint that
you can follow and number three how will
you take some immediate action today and
if you liked this video and promised you
take action after watching it give me a
hashtag belive down the comments as well
we don't just watch videos here we do
something about it so give me a hashtag
believe make that promise to yourself
and then get to work our mind wants to
protect us the mind is like honestly it
has a tactical advantage over us it
knows our deepest darkest fears or
insecurities it knows where we start to
feel we start getting that doubt creep
in that says hey man you know what man
maybe this isn't good let's go back home
to the wife it's good I call to the kids
this is not comfortable so in that
moment the mind directs us it's a
protective mechanism it saves us for
doing bodily harm or or it really saves
us from discovering that demise like I
want to be in charge of you I don't want
you to be in charge of me so it tells
you that's to stop right here but once
you start breaking through that barrier
and start breaking down that governor
the governor that you've put in your
mind because we forget we are in control
of our mind we believe it's the other
way around no we put in our minds what
we should do but we believe our mind is
telling us this give us all this
feedback we have to reprogram it and
tell us no no no we're good
we're good we got it this sucks but it's
okay
if you want to know the five morning
routines that are critical for success
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there you've
got to train yourself to be the kind of
person that doesn't use the snooze alarm
so there's a rule there's 30 minutes I
cannot touch my telephone